four of the 911 terrorists were here in
las vegas in the months before the
attack 20 years ago but we've not never
gotten a clear answer why our george
knapp spoke with clark county sheriff
joe lombardo about what we know about
that visit
it's 20 years since 9 11 and i've
interviewed former sheriffs your
predecessors over the years about why
the terrorists visited our city
no one's ever really came up with an
answer what insight do you have what
thoughts do you have about why they were
here so many times i'm sure you've heard
all the
the theories you know throughout the
years
and
especially in close to the incident
some of the people surmising why they
were in las vegas but to answer your
question george i don't know exactly
what it is i have my own opinion and i
guess that's what you're asking of me
um
the theory associated with it it would
be a nondescript
uh
meeting place from individuals coming
from disparate parts of the united
united states um and without
people
without being suspicious
i guess that would be the key word to
use um
individuals coming together ease of
coming together because of the the the
numbers of tourists that come here from
all walks of life they wouldn't stick
out
um be able to meet and then the other
part of the theory is is you know to
conduct some activities that they
weren't allowed to either based on their
religion or personal beliefs and through
martyrdom um they were able to cleanse
their souls associated with that so
that's the best analogy i could provide
you from my personal opinion you know
speaking with your predecessors in
previous years uh you know they had said
prior to 9 11 las vegas was not really
considered to be a threat to
foreign terrorists jihadists um boy
things have really changed since then
right
yeah it has i mean we've had some
incidences occur without the public
knowledge um in las vegas that we were
able to interdict sooner before anything
would happen um but then most of it
hasn't been foreign based it's been
domestic based um you know things that
people are aware of you know the millers
associated with officer beck and soldo
one
october uh
you know it wasn't classified as
terrorism i classified it as terrorism
domestic terrorism um but the under the
federal statute it wasn't but
those type of incidents are occurring
within the continental u.s now as
compared to that
traditional mindset or that vision of
terrorists being from a foreign
foreign country perpetrating their their
crimes or their crisis
amongst the continental us
talk to me about how 911 and subsequent
events changed metro um you and i have
had the discussion before about training
things that changed in response to not
just 911 but other mass murder events
around the world right right um
well i think it was a watershed
event
in the the
the
gaps the deltas associated with the
intel world
you know
how you get out of the 911 report more
importantly the most
salient issue and that was the lack of
information shared
the intel were was
bifurcated trifocated you know it was it
had tentacles going in every different
direction and nobody was talking with
each other and they discovered that
there was not pieces of knowledge
everywhere and if they had put it
together they probably could have
prevented 911 and so what had what has
occurred as a result of that is
you know internally in local law
enforcement counter-terrorism units have
been stood up on their own without
having to rely strictly on the federal
space you know your federal partners to
provide
assistance in that space because a lot
of things that we think are suspicious
at the local level on the state level is
not considered
suspicious at the federal level so we
thought it was important for us to be
more proactive